I was teased a lot because I'm
overweight when they puke liquor if you
just smeared that on your thighs yeah
big car a lot of it was behind my back
but then a lot of it was also to my face
you're a disgusting fat pig which made
me feel terrible
my name is Emmy and it's the first
plus-size supermodel trust me I know
what it's like to be judged based on my
size but I'm also a mom and now one of
my life's greatest passions is to be a
part of creating a world where children
can grow up happy successful and
fulfilled at any size obesity and
children and adults has doubled in the
past 20 years alarmingly it's tripled in
teens children as young as three years
old view overweight peers as mean stupid
ugly unhappy lazy having few friends and
undesirable as playmates hey route arrow
what's that your lunchbox my friend was
picked on by a teacher
he called her chubby and stuff and I
just thought that was very uncalled for
and a teacher shouldn't say some
anything like that people are afraid of
what's different from him oh look at
that shirt she was wearing her stomachs
popping out and everything like wide
load coming through it just felt wrong I
felt like I couldn't do anything about
it many students face this torment daily
it takes a toll on their emotional
physical health one study even found
that the quality of life for obese
children is as low as children with
cancer oh god here comes the earthquake
wait bias is very socially acceptable in
North American society it's rarely
challenged and it's often ignored
victims of weight bias are more
susceptible to loneliness depression
anxiety low self-esteem poor body image
and suicidal thoughts and behaviors we
believe that there's a strong social
injustice occurring here the hundreds of
millions of people around the world are
deeply affected by this and it just
doesn't need to occur race bias doesn't
need to occur gender bias doesn't need
to occur and weight bias doesn't need
her
you
you